[Música]
un poco nervioso, puede ser honesto, pero
al mismo tiempo no se trata de mí, se
trata de las personas que están sufriendo
allí, así que cuando ves las
imágenes, ves a las personas que están aquí.
ahora entiendes que no estás
sufriendo esto más por ellos
[Música]
en el Reino Unido, una
especie de área norte del Reino Unido Manchester
que antes um y básicamente estamos aquí
debido a los crímenes de guerra que se están
cometiendo,
el presidente preguntó
si él  puedo ayudar
y comencé a pensar en ello y luego
comencé a leer los crímenes de guerra y
ahí es cuando se vuelve repugnante
[Música]
[Aplausos] [
Música]
[Aplausos]
[Música]
luchar por la democracia
porque la
democracia es preciosa
y un hombre puede  decide que otro
país no debería tenerlo
[Música]
tú